اعلنت واشنطن فرض عقوبات تستهدف شخصيات من
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع
ومؤسسات وشركات تابعه او داعمه او متعامله
معهما وقالت واشنطن انها ستتخذ خطوات
اضافيه لاجل وقف القتال واعاده المسار
الديمقراطي ياتي ذلك بعد تعليق البلدين
الرعيين مباحثات جده واشتراطهم الالتزام
الجاد بمخرجاتها الاستئناف جلساتها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما رساله واشنطن الى
طرفي الصراع في السودان من خلال العقوبات
وكيف تلقى الطرفان الرساله الامريكيه اي
تاثيرات مباشره للعقوبات خصوصا في المجال
العسكري وما مدى نجاعتها في انهاء القتال
بالنظر الى المصير الذي انتهت اليه الهدن
التي سعت لذلك من قبل وكيف نفهم دلاله
الاعلان عن تعليق المحادثات بين طرفي
الصراع من قبل رعاته واي خطوات تصعديه
اخرى قد تلجا اليها واشنطن بحق طرفي
الصراع في المستقبل
[موسيقى]
لم تمر الولايات المتحده بعد نحو سرعه
القصوى في التعامل مع مجريات الصراع في
السودان لكنها غيرت فيما يبدو من نبره
خطابها واشهرت في وجه طرفيه سلاح العقوبات
على لسان اكثر من مسؤولا في الصف الاول
بالادارات الامريكيه جاء الخطاب حادا يتهم
الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع بانتهاكات خطيره
تقود جهود مباحثات جده وتسد الطريق امام
تسويه سلميه للنزاع الدامي وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن قال اننا مستعدون
لاتخاذ اجراءات اضافيه بهدف وقف القتال
واعاده السودان الى المسار الديمقراطي اما
منسق الاتصالات بمجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي فقال في نفس السياق على البرهان
وحميتي ادراك جديه معاقبه من يعرقل الحل
السياسي السفاره الامريكيه في الخرطوم ش
دون تفاصيل على انه تم ابلاغ طرفي الصراع
بما يجب اتخاذه لاثبات الالتزام بمباحثات
جده
ومخرجاتها وفي ردود الفعل قلل مصدر من
الجيش السوداني من تاثير العقوبات
الامريكيه على الجيش فيما اشار مصدر مقرب
من الدعم السريع الا ان الهدف منها انما
هو دفع الجيش وقوات الدعم لتقديم تنازلات
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن
السفير ديفيدشن مساعد وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي السابق لشؤون افريقيا معنى من
اندرمان احمد عمر خوجه الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ومن الخرطوم سينضم الينا السيد
حافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل السياسي مرحبا
بكم جميعا سنبدا معك سيد ديفيد اذا عقوبات
امريكيه على شركات مرتبطه بالجيش السوداني
وبقوات الدعم السريع لماذا تعتقد واشنطن
ان هذه الخطوه يمكن ان تنجح حيث اخفقت
المفاوضات باعتقادك
انا لست متاكدا ان واشنطن مدركه ان هذه
الخطوات ستكون ناجحه في ظل فشل خطوات اخرى
علينا ان نتذكر انه قبل سنتين تقريبا كان
هنالك عقوبات اهم تم فرضها على السودان
700 مليون دولار من المساعدات الامريكيه
تم تجميدها 6 مليارات دولار مساعدات من
البنك الدولي وصندوق النقد الدولي تم
تجميدها وبدعم الولايات المتحده وخمسين
مليار دولار من غاثه الديون تم ايقافها
هذه من الواضح لم تقنع اطراف المتصارعه في
وقتها في
تنهي الصراع بالتالي ما يحدث الان وما حصل
خلال الايام القليله الماضيه فان هو حركه
متواضعه العقوبات ضد اربع شركات سودانيه
مرتبطه بالجيش السوداني ومرتبطه بقواته
الدعم السريع وتلك الشركات لا تمتلك روابط
قويه مع الولايات المتحده الروابط هي اكبر
مع دول اخرى مثل سوريا روسيا عفوا
والامارات العربيه المتحده بالتالي ليس من
المحتمل ان يكون لهذه العقوبات تاثير كبير
واذا كان ليس من المحتمل ان يكون لها
تاثير كبير لماذا باعتقادك اقدمت الولايات
المتحده على هذه الخطوه بعد تعليق مفاوضات
جده
هذه هي احدى الادوات القليله التي ما تزال
واشنطن تمتلكها للضغط على القوات العسكريه
السودانيه وايضا قوات الدعم السريع ان
تقوم بالشيء الصائب هو ان تنهي وقف اطلاق
النار وتنهي قتل السوداني الى المدنيين
وكما قلت هي خطوه متواضعه هي ربما من
الخطوات القليله المتبقيه التي تمتلكها
الولايات المتحده الان
السيد عمر احمد عمر خوجلي
التقييم الاولي للقوات المسلحه لهذه
العقوبات ورد على لسان مصدر عسكري بالقول
انها ان هذه العقوبات لن تؤثر كثيرا لان
الجيش السوداني يقوم
كما قال يصنع اسلحته في داخل السودان
ما تقييمك لهذا الموقف
والله هذا هذا الحديث صحيح انه الجيش
السوداني لديه تجربه طويله مع الحصار ومع
منع
استمرار الصناعات العسكريه
واستجابه من الخارج تجربه طويله استمرت
لسنوات طويله الجيش تمكن في ختامها ان
يصنع الادوات والوسائل العسكريه والاسلحه
داخل السودان وهذا جهد تم والحصار قائم
والحصار كان اشد على ما هو الان بدا به
الان وكانت مبرراته اوجه مما هي عليه الان
الجيش الان يدافع
ويصب هو يعني تمرد عليه وترتكب فضائح كبرى
تجاه الشعب السوداني فضائح معروفه ومسهوره
وان كانت هناك اخطاء قليله بالمقارنه بما
يلتقوه الدعم السريع من خروقات كبيره
اذا كانت الولايات المتحده جاد فعلا في
الحفاظ على ارواح المواطنين وممتلكاتهم
فكان بالاولى ان تختصر هذه العقوبات على
الذي نرى ونسمع ونشاهد انتهاكات الكبيره
اذا كان من انتهاكات قليله بسبب صدر
الهجمات التي يقوم بها الدعم السريع فكان
الاولى ان تعتبر جزء من حاله الدفاع وهي
قليله لمقارنه الدعم السريع وفي هذه ورد
على لسان مصدر عسكري سوداني ان هناك
استغراب لان الولايات المتحده لان تضع
الولايات المتحده الطرفين في كفه واحده
كما قال هذا المصدر العسكري ولكن حديث
الطرفين الان سيد عمر من ناحيه الجيش بان
هذه العقوبات لن تؤثر ومن ناحيه اخرى حديث
الدعم السريع على لسان المستشار السياسي
لقوات الدعم السريع ايضا لقوله ان هذه
العقوبات لن تؤثر وهي لا تؤثر وقد اثبتت
التجربه ذلك ماذا يفهم من وراء هذين
الموقفين بالنسبه
لمستقبل هذه المواجهات العسكريه
انه لن يؤثر هذا هذا مجرب وهذا ثابت
بالتجربه ولكن القول المستشار السياسي
القوات الدعم السريع بانه لم يؤثر عليه
هذا هذا هراء لان الدعم السريع عقيدتها
القتاليه الاتي تشتغل بها الان
منذ تاسيسها وحتى الان تقوم على المال
تقوم على المصالح الماليه تقوم على
العلاقات الماليه تقوم على بيع الذهب تقوم
على نهب المواطنين وممتلكات المواطنين
العقيده الماليه الماديه التي تقوم عليها
عقيده القوات الدعم السريع في جلب المصالح
والمقارن هذه هذه عقيده الان نراها كل يوم
هذه العقيده ماليه وهذا الحصار وهذا وهذا
وهذا القرار هذه القرارات الامريكيه الان
تحجم من هذه العمليات ومن صادرات ومن
التعاملات التي تجلب الارباح لهذه القوه
هذا القرار بشكل كبير يؤثر هذه على قوه
الدعم السري طيب انضم الينا الان من
الخرطوم السيد حافظ كبير الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي سيد حافظ كبير مرحبا سنشركك معنا
في هذا النقاش اذا نفس السؤال وحيله احيله
اليك المستشار السياسي لقوات الدعم السريع
يقول ان التجربه اثبتت ان العقوبات لا
تؤثر وابرز دليل على ذلك ما حصل مع النظام
السابق الذي عاش سنوات طويله في ظل
العقوبات الدوليه عليه ماذا نفهم من هذا
الكلام بالنسبه لي الخطوات المقبله وكيفيه
التعامل قوات الدعم السريع مع هذه الخطوه
الامريكيه
هذا الجواب ربما يكون عاما هناك تاثير
بالطبع والا لم افرض العقوبات لكن يعني في
ماذا هذا التاثير يعني هل سيؤثر على
مجريات الحرب ام سيسر على الدوله ام سيؤثر
على تعديل سلوك النظام باعتبار اننا الان
يعني الواجهه وضعا مختلف حول تعريفاته
الجيش السوداني لديه مصالح ولديه مؤسسات
تحتاج الى التعاون الدولي واي عقوبات في
هذا الاطار تحجم من الجيش وتجعل من فاعليه
وشركاتهم امرا يعني مشكوك فيه كذلك ربما
مع الذين يعني
يعملون خارج النظام الان نحن
نحن الان امام وضع يعني
اعلانيه اذا كان ذلك كذلك فان العقوبات
كثيرا بالطبع
اما فيما يخص الدعم السريع فان التاثير
بطبعه سيكون اقل باعتبار انه لا يتعامل
حاليا مع الدوله وليس لديه علاقات خارجيه
ولا يدعى لذلك سواء ان الدوله يعني كيان
كيان العقوبات استهدفت الشركه التي يعتمد
عليها ماليا تعتمد عليها ماليا قوات الدعم
السريع
بالطبع لا يعتبر لا يعتمد الدعم السريع
على الشركه وهذه الشركات باسماء اشخاص
واستعمل السريع مؤسسه حتى الخامس من ابريل
مؤسسه بعد الدوله ميزانيه وتصدر من
الحكومه السودانيه وكذلك بقاره وكذلك كل
اجراءاته كانت تتبع للدوله وبالتالي ولا
يعتمد على هذه الشركات نحن نعلم ان
الشركات هي شركه مملوكه لعبد الرحيم رئيس
هذا لا يعني انها شركه الدعم السريع هي
شركه شخص ولا علاقه لها بصوره مباشره
بالدعم السريع اما الشركات مؤسسه وبالتالي
العقوبات ستؤثر عليها بالطبع
او علقت المنبر وهذا تاثير مباشر لهذه
العقوبات وبالتالي نعلم ان هذه العقوبات
دوليه خاصه انها تهدف فيما تهدف الى تعديل
سلوك الاطراف ونجحت في ذلك وبالتالي نحن
الان موقف جديد للجيش يعني هذا الموقف
مختلف تماما على الموقف السابق عندما
انسحب
هناك بالفعل تعديل في سلوك الاطراف ابقى
معي السيد حافظ كبير اعود
اليكشن من واشنطن استمعت الى وجهه نظر
الطرفين بان هذه العقوبات لن تؤثر وانت
قلت ايضا ان هذه العقوبات تمثل حركه
متواضعه اذا هل كان من المنطق تعليق
المفاوضات التي كانت تحصل في جده بين
الطرفين
ريثما يتم تعديل السلوك هل بغياب هذه
المفاوضات وبهذه الحركه المتواضعه كما
اسميتها المتمثله بفرض عقوبات يمكن فعلا
ان تتعدل
السلوكيات الطرفين على الارض وان
تخف وتيره المواجهات العسكريه
الولايات المتحده
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه قامت
المحادثات لان احد الطرفين وربما كلاهما
بالتاكيد فان القوات
الجيش السوداني قرر ان يتراجع وينسحب من
المحادثات في الوقت الحالي ولم يكن هنالك
اي امكانيه للمضي قدما بالتالي فان القرار
الواضح تم اتخاذه ان يكون هنالك ايقاف
للمحادثات بين الطرفين المشاركين العقوبات
كما اشرت لها هي متواضعه في ناحيه التاثير
الذي سيكون لها قد يكون من الاهم قد تكون
اكثر اهميه لو قانت هنالك اطراف اخرى اخرى
تفاعلت مع الشركات السودانيه المرتبطه مع
القوات السودانيه والقوات الدعم السريع
لربما ايضا اخذت هذه العقوبات بجديه ومثلا
اوقفت المواد الخام واجزاء التي او
المعدات واي معدات اخرى
تحتاجها تلك الشركات من اجل الاستمرار
بالعمل لكن ليس من الواضح ان هذا الامر
سيحدث وخاصه في حاله الشركه المرتبطه مع
قوه الدعم
بالتالي في ظل هذا الوضع هل ترى انه كان
منطقيا تعليق هذه المفاوضات في جده وهي
كانت ربما قناه التفاوض الوحيده الموجوده
بين الطرفين
اعتقد انك من المنطقي ايقافها لكن هذا لا
يعني انها انتهت
بامكان ان يتم اعاده هذه المفاوضات اذا ما
رغب الطرفاني بالعوده اليها عمر خوجلي
ماذا وراء استقدام تعزيزات كبيره الان
للجيش السوداني الى الخرطوم خصوصا بعد
حديث البرهان في اخر تصريح مصور له ان
الجيش لم يستخدم بعد كامله قوته للحفاظ
على المدنيين في ظل هذه العقوبات وفي ظل
تعليق
المفاوضات في جده ما الذي ينتظر ان يحدث
على الارض
الحديث عن الهدى الكثيره والانهيار
الاتفاق الاخير هو يجب ان نبداه بان الجيش
السوداني كان في حاله هدنه مستمره من نفسه
ومن حرصه على حيوات والممتلكات العامه
والكباري لذلك كان يستخدم القوى الادنى في
في صراعه مع اعتداء قوات الدعم السريع
لذلك الان لا هدنه ولا التزام
والبسيطين يعني عن لقاء محاولاتهما فان
الجيش السوداني الذي كان يعني يحاول ان
يحافظ بقدر الامكان على على المواقع
السكنيه وعلى كل ذلك الان بعد الفترات
طويله من الصبر ومن الجهد الفني الدقيق
الان يحاول ان يدخل بحرصه على الحيوانات
الاخرين وعدد مرافق المدنيه ان يدخل في
هذه المعركه بالقوه التي تؤهله لطرد
العدوان والذي
تحجيم قوات الدعم السريع من محاولات ها
المستمره في المحافظه على مواقعها
الاستراتيجيه بل والتعدي على مواقع اخرى
كما هو في المهندسين او في المطار الحربي
في وادي سيدنا ينتظر بعد اكثر مما حصل
الجيش السوداني الان يحاول ان ان يضغط من
خلال الانتصار العسكري الكاسي الذي كان
يعني
يؤخره من حركته حرصه على التزام بالهدن
المختلفه واحترامه للشركه للوسيطين بنك
السعودية والولايات المتحده الان الالتزام
ولا هدنه واعتداءات القوات الدعم السريع
المستمره فالان الجيش يدخل بحملته الكامله
وبقدراته الهائله ويحاول ان يصد العدوان
وان يثبت هذا العدوان لان كلما استمرت
قوات الدعم السريع في ايجاد الفرص
المختلفه عن طريق الهدى التي لا تلتزم بها
تجد مواقع جديده وتحاول ان تسيطر على
مواقع اضافيه استراتيجيه كما على ذكرتي لك
في المطار او في سلاح المهندسين حافظ كبير
بغياب حتى يعني شبه هدنه لان ما كان يحدث
في الماضي هذه الهدن لا يتم الالتزام بها
ولكن حتى بغياب هذا الشيء الضئيل
كيف باعتقادك يمكن ان تتحول الامور
ميدانيا
وانا اعتقد ان الامور ميدانيا كانت متروكه
للتوازن الضعف او القوه داخل العاصمه
وكذلك ما تمثله يعني انتصارات او سيطرت
قوات الدعم السريعه على اماكن استراتيجيه
التي يحاول الدعم يحاول الجيش اخراجها
بالتفاوض فيما عجز عن ذلك بالقتال اعتقد
ان
القوه المميته التي يتحدث عنها الجيش لا
اعتقد ان الذي يستخدم سابقا لم يكن لم
يدخل في تصنيف القوه المميته حيث نحن
تابعنا العشرات او حتى الان بلغ عدد
القتلى في هذه الحرب اكثر من الف وبالتالي
هذه قوه مميته دمرت كثير من المرافق
العامه عبر الطائرات الحربيه وكذلك
المدفعيه
يعني لان ايضا الطرف الاخر متهم بنفس
الطرف الاخر ايضا متهم بذلك
نحن نتحدث عن الذي يملك الطائرات ويملك
المدفعيه ثقيل الدعم السريع معلوم انه قوه
خفيفه تملك مدافع خفيفه في المربوطه او
مثبته على السيارات وبالتالي هذه تستخدم
في المعارك اما اما الجيش فهو يستخدم
الطائرات ويستخدم المدفعيه لضرب بالاماكن
من بعيد وهذا يضر بالطبع بالمنشات
بالمدنيين اعتقد ان سير العمليات سيستمر
بهذه الوتيره ليس هناك تغيير كبير سيحدث
اذا كان من تغيير كان سيحدث في معارك
الطيبه الاخيره معركه التي كانت بريه ولم
تكون في ارض ماهوله بالسكان كانت في غابات
وكانت في اماكن يعني بعيده عن المواطنين
لكن لم يتغير ميزان القوه وظلت قوات الدعم
السريع تحتفظ بهذا المعسكر المهم معسكر
طيبه كانت جيش يقول بانه دمر كل المعسكرات
لكن يتضح الان ان هناك معسكرات ما يزال
الدعم السريع محتفظ بها بل زاد من من
نفوذه في معسكرات اخرى كانت تتبع للجيش
وبالتالي هذا الامر يجعل من التفاوض يعني
نحن نتحدث الان
لسنا في خضم غزو اجنبي حتى يتم التعامل
معه باعتباره فقط دحره هناك خيارات اخرى
مثل الذي يدور في جده الحوار والتفاوض
والخيار ايضا الهدن الانسانيه كذلك الجميع
ينطلق تغير سلوك الطرفين دون العوده الى
دون العوده الى مفاوضات جده تغير سلوك
الطرفين الالتزام بالهدنه هل ترى ان هناك
امكانيه لذلك باختصار
سيتغير سلوك الاطراف سيلتزمون بالعوده الى
التفاوض غدا ستنتهي الهدنه الموقفه او
الخمسه ايام سيعود الاطراف الى التفاوض
وسيتغير سلوكهم وسيلتزمون بذلك سيتزمون
بكثير من النقاط التي لم يلتزم بها سابقا
واعتقد ان ميزان القوه كما ذكرت لك لم
يتغير ولن يتغير في المستقبل وبالتالي ليس
هناك خيار جديد
بما تم التوقيع عليه في جده اذا كان ماذا
بعد العقوبات في ظل هذه المخاوف من ان
يعني تفلت الامور نهائيا ميدانيا بغياب اي
هدنه بغياب اي مفاوضات ماذا بعد كيف يمكن
التعامل مع ما يحدث في السودان
ووقف هذه المواجهات العسكريه والمسؤولون
الامريكيون يؤكدون انهم ملتزمون بذلك
الجزء الاهم بالتاكيد هو المضي قدما فيما
يتعلق بوقف اطلاق النار ان كلا الطرفين
عليهما ان يحترما وقف اطلاق النار اذا لم
يحدث ذلك فما سيحصل هنالك استمرار للصراع
المستمر هو الخاصر الاكبر هو الشعب
السوداني هم الذين يعانون بشكل اكبر من
هذا الصراع الدول مثل الولايات المتحده
ما الذي سيلزم الاطراف على الالتزام
بالهدنه ان كانوا عندما كانت هناك مفاوضات
تحدث في جده وهم لم يلتزموا ما الذي
سيلزمهم الان
على علم باي خطوات بامكاني ان تجبر اي من
الطرفين على احترامي وقف اطلاق النار
مساله القوات الدفع الدعم السريع والجيش
عليهم ان يتخذوا القرار على انهم
مصلحه الشعب السوداني ان يكون هنالك وقف
اطلاق النار اي قوه خارجيه لا يمكنها ان
تجبر اطراف الصراع على القيام بذلك شكرا
السفير الامريكي السابق لشؤون افريقيا
ومساعد وزير الخارجيه السابق شكرا لضيفنا
من ام درمان احمد عمر خوجه للكاتب والمحلل
السياسي ولضيفنا من الخرطوم حافظ كبير
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا الى هنا تنتهي هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]